you want to oscar comfortable he's
second in the major leagues in home runs
right-hander deals and the first pitch
is hit in the air out to straight away
center field it's hit well to center
field and go on in center field
tay oscar hernandez with number 14.
he is now tied for the major league lead
in home runs
bottom of the second inning jd martinez
high fly ball and left center field that
one's a deep drive and that ball is gone
he spanked it jd martinez with number
four on the season he's starting to come
to life jackie is hit safely in seven in
a row
that includes the bunt and this one is
going to be ripped deep to right back it
goes god into the bullpen he's some kind
of hot right now that's going to be a
two-run homer and the red sox grab a 3-1
lead against anderson and toronto and
very funny guys
that one torn into that's it wickedly to
the wall and that ball is gonna get out
of here
it's a home run
barely over the top of the monster
bobby delbeck with his second major
league home run that was a laser beam
and now it yanks one into right field
for a base hit and this one will get to
the fence teles is on his way to third
and rowdy is getting the way
the throw comes into second teles will
score on a double by shaw and the blue
jays creep a little closer
now
it's that one fair pass the diving
guerrero and that means two runs will
come on into score he say dahlberg
scores and verdugo scores and the red
sox lead in six to two vr is grounded
out two times does have a base runner
with one away
there's a drive to left center field
this is trouble jackie won't be able to
get it it's up on the green he grabs the
caramana up here's the throw to second a
chance to get vajar and he's out joe
it's not just throw which in and of
itself is breathtaking
it is the idea that he knows exactly
where to go to wait for that karim he
plays it on the hop on the bare hand
spins and throws a strike
out at second and hernandez at first the
blue jays looking to cut into the four
run deficit here in the sixth inning
and guerrero launches a high fly ball
left center field
and gone on a three-run homer for vladi
to make it a one-run game
guerrilla gets on top of this fastball i
mean this is a moon shot
high and deep to center
and he takes one look at jackie bradley
jr knows that he's not going to catch it
and he's not going to come close to this
thing and look who's up it'll be oscar
hernandez two for three including a home
run
it's a fastball and lines it into left
field for a base hit
rounding third heading home is grechik
the throw comes into third and teles
will be tagged out there
but a run will score to tie the game at
six
taking second on the play is hernandez
but again if panic reaches it looks like
bishop will pinch in
the 2-0 and a liner into right field a
base hit
giving chase for dugo rounding third and
heading home hernandez guerrero will
stop it third it's a double for panic
and the blue jays have the lead and what
a job by joe panic he has really turned
it up a notch the o2 to gorilla
and a bouncer over the mound gonna be a
tough play they won't get anybody
another run will come into score on the
infield single and it's eight to six
devers to lead it off he has doubled in
two runs he's one for three raffy
launching that one high drive deep to
right backing up and she's gone split
thinking fastball didn't do anything
stayed right out over the plate and
devins punched it
sander has been silenced he's gone over
four so he's due
high fly ball that one left field that's
way up there that ball is gone home run
xander bogarts with number nine and he
has tied the game
at eight eight
in the last of the ninth inning well he
was due
and he crushed it and so he winds up at
third a stolen base and an error on the
catcher everybody in so the red sox can
win the ball game right here
1-2 to munoz
swinging a chopper trying to send a
runner home wide throw he's in and the
red sox win the ball game
baskets got in to throw us off target
and the sox win it nine to eight
that's your final tonight at fenway in a
wild one
and it ends that way
christian vasquez
stealing a base advancing to third on
the throwing error by the catcher
bass coughs it up
not to be forgotten a blast by xander
bogars that allowed all that to happen
and who would guess vasquez speed would
have won the game yes
[Applause]